[Musique]
des jeunes qui vivent dans la rue on en
rencontre dans les quartiers populaires
de toutes les grandes villes ils se
retrouvent en bande
chaque soir il était dans un square
hiver au point d'un trottoir quand vous
les entendez chahuté ou faire pétarader
leur moto savez vous que certains ne
savent pas au coucher cette nuit car si
dans les bornes au tour des garçons qui
ont une famille quant à l'école font un
métier régulier d'autres sont vraiment à
la rue nous voulions ce soir découvrir
pourquoi ils en sont là mais tout
d'abord que pense-t-il les autres jeunes
de ce qu'ils appellent des snobs et que
pense-t-il de vous le monde des adultes
comme quoi comme vendeur
qu'est ce que vous faites pas pour
l'instant je suis libre aux parents ils
sont d'accord le soir battus et tués par
la bombe
c'est plus la map des blousons noirs new
show et lewis alors oui c'est sa pleine
lune y sont pas au fait qu'est-ce que
c'est un snob assez simple l'arrière je
prends au milieu les quoi faire tuer
crêpés quoi lui portons costume croisé
ces bonnes chaussures de ce noble a
diminué
son imper avec le cd boucle derrière
quoi avec la main comme ça voilà une
nous regardent ils nous disent regardez
moi ça ils ont de lewis sont
dégueulasses et ouais ouais si quentin
cela vous regarde qu'est-ce qui se passe
ben on regarde aussi quand on en a marre
sont allés puisse aller aussitôt que
vous êtes plus nombreux ça fait des
histoires assez fait des blagues à vous
embêter les gens quoi mais non mais
c'est un réflexe pour des cons et
plusieurs séries qui viennent et au
square la côte est vraiment ça se
paraient au square c'est par
l'intermédiaire des gardiens voyez
pourquoi garder les squares vais pas
bien comme il voit qu on les emmerde
hannah où les amériques
on joue au foot voyez pas doit jouer au
foot
non mais après on a joué au foot après
nous emmerder alors on les à chambrer un
peu finalement et garçons 14 17 ans et
qui sans les banques
qu'est ce qu'ils voient comme un dieu
ben ils voient ils voient que les
adultes petit point c'est à côté d'eux
des adultes soit poussé carte se
retourne alors desjoyeaux bon à rien et
tout alors on aime pour les adultes
enfin bon point de vue il comprenait pas
qu'on pouvait faire des trucs comme ça
qu'on a les cheveux aussi longs qu'on en
soit on était pour salma paraissait
savez tout alors rien qui a lover c'est
l uniforme même qu on n y ont rien fait
il cherchait pourra comprendre
cherchez pas où c'est que le mal qu'on
avait fait n'est rien du tout ils
voyageront avait un blouson noir on
était des n'était plus grandes salles
d'athènes valérien
tous comment vous voyez quand vous aurez
25 ans comme l'ignoriez quand vous aurez
25 ans on va choper demander si lent
mais si vous n'êtes pas mort vous aurez
l'impression que ça va changer vous
continuerez avec la borne les copains ça
voilà j'espère que ça dure toute la vie
devant chrome pas
y'a un moment se marient non
non
l'appartement la petite voiture
la petite femme les enfants
à aquila la maternité
et vous comment vous voyez quelques
heures et vingt-cinq ans doit on se
loupe son milliards d'eur
leurs motos sur tout ce qu'ils possèdent
c'est leur seule manière de s'imposer de
s'assurer qu'ils existent pour le reste
un horizon qui s'arrêtent aux autos
tamponneuses et aux machines à sous
on ne sait jamais de quoi demain sera
fait même ceux qu'on mangera ce soir on
vit au jour le jour sans apprendre un
métier
on ne pense même pas qu'un jour il
faille vivent autrement
beaucoup de jeunes entre 15 et 20 ans
tourne dans ce cercle
quelques-uns en sorte trois jeunes
hommes qui sont passés par là mais qui
exerce aujourd'hui un métier qui ont
fondé un foyer ont accepté de se
souvenir de ce qu'ils étaient leurs
femmes ont bien voulu nous apporter
elles aussi leurs témoignages quatre en
quatre et vous avez quel âge 24 ans et
22 ans
est ce que je peux vous demander de quel
est votre métier l'onglet qu'elle
impressionnant les filles qui vont comme
ça dans les bandes sur les gars on les
admire les peut les admirer non pas
tellement d'enfants la voir au début et
les admire un peu elles sont fières par
exemple si la fréquentation c'est le
voyait faire de bêtises si à voyais que
tout le monde l'admirent que tous ses
camarades l'admirent qu'ils en ont peur
de l'impression d'être des hommes enfin
des durs
alors évidemment ça ça s'est toujours
bien ça faisait même mieux que tu es
jeunes gens rangées bien ça moi à
l'époque où il ya quinze ans je trouvais
ça muc car je laime bien rangées bien
sage bien habillé l'espèce d'admiration
oui c'était l'admiration mais je crois
que ses débuts qui ont été difficiles
pour commencer a commencé mais il a
fallu que que je me réadapte à la vie
civile après avoir fait un séjour en
maison de redressement de 6 en six ans
maintenant qu'elle a la clé de 12 ans à
18 ans beaucoup bavé d'égal que je
connaissais très bien que moi par
exemple mon père buvait
c'était quand je rentre à la maison pas
encaisser mais en attendant pas de la
porte pour me disent il peut pas rentrer
parce qu'il t'a temps où il y en a
d'autres et pas celui qui vivent tout
seul indépendant ou alors là la mère qui
est en sérieuse où le père
ils sont complètement livre à l'eau même
quand ils arrivent ils à mende il trouve
refuge parmi les peuples construit ce
qui est élevé par ma grand mère oui et
puis on sortant de l'école mon père ma
place et non un centre d'apprentissage
puis j'ai pour voulu rester pourquoi ça
vous plairait part je voulais pour être
commandés voulait plus je voulais être
libre un peuple j'avais aucune
intervention particulière du côté
professionnel pour la bonne raison que
voulait pas travailler
je voulais loyer beaucoup d'argent et
puis j'avais pour faire grand chose que
monsieur g répondent métier un jour je
travaillais dans le camion neige comme
livreur le lendemain j'ai été coursier à
vélo jamais faisait jamais la même chose
jamais rien qui me plaisait quand on a
de l'argent mais si on ne travaille pas
c'est rare mais là on fait ça pour
s'amuser brouille dire qu'on fait
quelques petits larcins de temps en
temps ou alors au terme en dernière
limite on va travailler une semaine j'ai
tout bien bassement ap commence la
délinquance que certains tourner
complètement à dr bah oui c'est le
départ des bus ont fait ça par nécessité
puis après on y prend goût est ce que
vous pensez qu'on peut s'en tirer tout
seul je pense que sentirais tout seul
c'est un cas très rares fautes faut
toujours est aidé par un adulte quand
même qui qui qui hélas non seulement
comme quelqu'un qui écoute millions de
plus qui participent dire que qui
pensent les problèmes avec le gars vous
ça s'est passé commun comme ça que j'ai
rencontrés pour la première fois un
homme
il m'a écouté et qui n'a fait aucune
critique aucune règle toutes les bêtises
que j'ai pu faire qui m'a écoutée au
lieu de faire semblant comme la plupart
et surtout c'est surtout le fait d'avoir
pu parler et de me libérer
intérieurement avec cette personne qui
m'a soulagé énormément et à partir du
moment où on est soulagé on voit des
choses beaucoup mieux jusqu'à jusqu'à
jusqu'à ce jour là j'avais rencontré que
des murs j'ai rencontré un homme qui m'a
compris qui s'est occupé de da - les
copains qui a organisé des voyages
qu'ils mais sans nous dire faut faire
s'il faut faire ça sans nous sans nous
faire la morale quoi petit à petit on
s'est amené à lui
oui et puis on l'a écouté et puis à la
fin comme il avait été très gentil avec
nous quoi il avait confiance on avait
confiance en lui
si on avait un enduit ont tout de suite
ils venaient cherchait pas avoir à
savoir qui c'est qu'ils avaient tort ou
à raison il nous défendait toujours quoi
alors à la fin on avait peur de faire
des bêtises de peur de contrarier quoi
on en faisait toujours un petit peu
nombreuses et moins qu'avant c'est enfin
que votre femme atteint quand il aura 15
ans s'il dit moi j'en ai assez de rester
à la maison je voudrais bien les avec
les gars qui font qu'ils sont en bande
là bas qu'est ce que vous lui direz
j'essaierai de l'expliquer que pour par
la violence ni par les coûts parce que
les coûts sur les prix et puis qui sait
pourquoi serais je suis arrivé sur une
expliqué que c'est pourquoi il faut
qu'ils fassent
ou trois mois
[Musique]